what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start make sure you like the
video on your way and that is the most
important metric that YouTube uses to
push out these live streams please guys
let's get to 2 000 likes a like is free
also guys get yourself a women shouldn't
vote t-shirt today are you tired of me
covering all these stories about women's
craziness are you tired of marriage
going down the drain well none of these
issues would have happened if women
didn't think we were equal by giving us
the right to vote I mean what they think
we're just as logical as the men are you
crazy
um and plus all these women will just
come up to you and be like wow what a
handsome alpha male what an amazing
t-shirt they're just gonna come up and
say hello
um okay so today we have a bunch of
different stories that we're going to
cover or so
um the first is that guys guys you won't
even believe it
I got on the UK Daily Mail I couldn't I
couldn't I woke up I couldn't believe
this for my tweets
um at adam22 now guys I want to show you
guys something you know they have money
they have Fame but they don't have
values and you know what's really crazy
about this whole situation and what what
this shows is that not Everything That
Glitters Is Gold speaking of gold the US
dollar has lost 85 of its value since
the 70s which was also guys what a woman
voted policy right get yourself the
women should have vote shirts but okay
so when the dollar decoupled from gold
and the government was just bent on
continuing this tradition of inflation
but now until after the next election
the government can print as much money
as they want thank you Biden
um and the last time they did that
inflation went up nine percent gold is
the only asset that has proven to
withstand inflation invest in gold with
gold Noble Investments you'll get a 24
Karat quarter ounce gold standard coin
for free go to
noblegoldinvestments.com now that's
noblegoldinvestments.com or simply dial
1-877-646-5347 it's the only gold
company that I trust so back to Adam 22.
so I wake up right and I I have this
people are sending me this article on
The Daily Mail UK and
um you know this is the picture they
gave which I also honestly think's a
great picture of me women shouldn't vote
get your T-shirt there was an article
that came out of me by The Daily Mail
and the title was adam22 was slammed by
female Andrew Tate Pearl Davis who
accused him of cucking out his porn star
wife Lena the plug and ruining the
sanctity of marriage
okay accused there's video evidence of
this like what do you you can't even say
accused what there's evidence that this
happened so okay all right let's let's
break this down the tweet that they have
on on the title of this is the one I
showed you guys yesterday I didn't know
marriage was cucking out your wife at
the expense of your children if that's
what marriage is I'd rather die alone
why do people like you get married why
insult religious people by making a
mockery of the sacrament and guys this
is what we've lost in this Society now
it's just like a promise it's like a
maybe and the average marriage is seven
eight years because we're more focused
on the wedding than the marriage you
know I I never hear wives talk about
being their husbands help me I never
hear them talking about obeying and
submitting to their husband's Authority
but I hear I but I do hear them talk
about their big ass wedding that had 300
people at it their cake
um and all of the things they do for the
wet I mean our our whole lives we hear
all these chicks plan their entire
wedding down to the T but not anything
about how their marriage will be so it
says in the world of social media
influencers and online controversies a
heated Clash has emerged between two
prominent figures anti-feminist
influencer Hannah Pearl Davis and no
jumper podcaster Adam Grand Mason also
known as adam22 their Feud revolves
around the topic of marriage and it's a
story of contrasting viewpoints and
sharp exchanges Hannah Pearl Davis a 26
year old with a substantial following on
YouTube is known for a conservative and
controversialy Views accuse Adam of
cucking out his wife and ruining the
sanctity of marriage
okay that word again accused I mean I
haven't seen it but you all of you
freaking people tweet at me little parts
of the video I'm so tired oh my gosh I
am so tired of all these porn stars and
only fans models on Twitter tweeting at
me their stuff their stuff the other
models anytime I make a tweet about only
fans do you know how many people I've
had to block because they just tweeted
me they're disgusting like why can't I
go on Twitter and not be bombarded with
this stuff anyways okay
she didn't hold back with comments like
your definition of marriage is letting
another dude bang your wife on camera
people like you are ruining the sanctity
of marriage it's an insult to people
that take marriage seriously guys
imagine if I got the nun outfit on
became a nun and then shot a porno after
you'd be like okay well why did you why
did you do all that to just you know
what I mean it's like why can't they
just stay in their box over there and
not
and not insult the people that are
actually religious you know
the feud had its roots when Andrew Tate
a self-proclaimed misogynist influencer
criticized Adam 22 for his adult film
star Lena the plug to film explicit
content shortly after their wedding no
no no no he started it okay I wasn't
even gonna cover I wasn't even gonna
cover that whole thing because me and
Adam had an interview and I was like you
know he he seems nice
but then I saw him talking about me
call me a misogynist
oh
me a misogynist I think the real
misogyny is cooking out your wife
he he manages porn star women and
it's like okay are women good with money
what what is the life cycle of these
women that he manages
um clearly I mean I've seen the girl he
manages that blonde chick come on
podcasts
and say that now dating is harder right
um do are women good with money are they
typically responsible with it no so
who's the real misogynist I'm just
telling you what's gonna happen Okay so
months of online bickering ensued with
Adam 22 eventually firing back at Davis
for a mocking only fan stars like
himself and his wife he resorted now
mind you this tweet wasn't even about
him I this had nothing to do with him I
was just tweeting about only fans he
resorted no offense but you should be
more worried about nobody wanting to
marry you right now
Davis didn't back down attacking Adam
22's marriage and stating if that's what
your marriage is then I'd rather die
alone why do people like you get married
why insult religious people by making a
mockery of the sacrament I mean Adam 22
defended his marriage by emphasizing his
commitment to nursian prompting Davis to
argue that people like this seem to be
shamed out of marriage and accused him
of offending religious people who take
marriage seriously
the exchanges took a personal turn when
Davis shared an explicit content from
adam22's online presence wait why would
they didn't like that okay took a it
took a personal turn
he attacked me personally first I had a
tweet that said what if I I it was a
genuine it was so funny this tweet
wasn't even inspired by him and his wife
I mean his wife if they stay married
that she'll be okay but it was inspired
by all the only fans models that come on
my show and they'll have no plan no no
money no job prospects they might have
money now but they they'll even
self-admittedly be bad with money so
they have no future plans and I'm like
what what are these chicks gonna do like
what what's gonna what's the what's the
end game for them
oh and so I tweeted and I had to blur
this out okay because I had to unfollow
adam22 on Instagram because his stuff
was just too explicit after the podcast
I told him this and then you know I'm on
Twitter and there's this there's this
picture of him his wife and another
chick doing this like sexual thing and
I'm like why Twitter
why why do I need to see this ew I I
tweeted a picture and I blurred out I
put some lines over the gross parts and
I'm the one going personal
he came personally at me for you should
experience an orgasm at least once
before you die and you might begin to
understand
you know I okay let me get this straight
that's gonna make me want to do porn
really
really that's that's the logical
conclusion here
um all right throughout this Feud it's
evident that Davis and Adam 22 hold
contrasting beliefs about the sanctity
of marriage and lifestyle choices their
story unfolds as they continue to defend
their perspectives
in the public arena with each comment
adding fuel of this online Clash
well you know honestly he started it I
don't
I don't start these things you know I
just I just I mean I
I said only nice things until things
were said about me you know
um but whatever you know I honestly wish
him well I hope they do well I just
genuinely think that it's offensive to
people that are religious I think
letting people like this into marriage
is offensive I think it's offensive to
have gay marriage count as marriage
marriage is a religious Sacrament
between a man and a woman and it's a
promise to God if you are not religious
that's fine just go do the girlfriend
boyfriend thing anyway we're we're
basically in a post-marriage society so
like what's the point and it you know I
I'm a Catholic and it's it's just like
you think about how seriously like you
know I mean
2023 I mean not not every Catholic takes
it seriously but you know like I just
think of like
what what that means you know when we
when we talk about the sacraments you
know we have first communion we have
confession
um then we have we have marriage right
like this is a religious ceremony
um and that's why I just think the
government needs to be out of marriage
to be honest because
um then you have people like this it's
like they're playing pretend you know
sure you get the white dress
um and you get to do the ceremony it's
fun great but it's like why
must you call it marriage call it
something else I don't know what but I
just I think there's too many people
that take marriage so seriously and are
are so religious devout Christians
Catholics Muslims who who just this is
offensive like this is I don't know what
else you would call it it's offensive
and this is kind of What's led to in my
opinion three generations of shitty
wives now guys there's always
traditionalists in any culture but I
really think the last gener three
generations of wives have been so
enthralled by Propaganda that they
really have nothing to teach my
generation
um and you know I'm gonna give you an
example of how I can see this
um is how little the last two
generations of women that were wives
know what men want
and the first time I I experienced this
was when I I tweeted that 25 year old
women are hotter than 35 year old women
in all of these traditional conservative
wives really had to prove their hotness
to me imagine that this was so funny um
if you guys don't know about a couple
months ago I tweeted that 25 year old
women were hotter than 35 year old women
and guys that tweet probably gave me the
most like internet bullying I've ever
received in my life now look if I say if
you can't take the heat get out of the
game so whatever like it is what it is
but
these women posted pictures of me called
me
ugly and they just these grown women you
know some were actually quote unquote
traditional conservatives
said they had to prove their hotness to
me so they were posting their selfies
like I'm talking like like women in the
conservative movement I said oh my gosh
Pearl I'm 26. and she was maybe 36 37.
Pearl thinks she's hotter than
today I need to wake up and prove my
hotness to Twitter
that's what I gotta do I just need to
wake up and show everybody how hot I am
and you know this is crazy because you
know
the most traditional wives don't get
their validation from me or any external
Source they get their validation from
their husband and that really signals to
me that something is off where
even at their age
they don't even know what men want men
like young hot chicks guys I don't know
what to tell you I'm not saying like I'm
the epitome of it but I'm saying like
you you look at Hollywood you know when
women watch a movie any any male movie
right when you think of like
Transformers who was in it
Megan Fox and it's so funny Margot
Robbie what when she was at her hottest
she was in Wolf of Wall Street who
watches that men when she kind of aged
out she's in movies for women she's in
Barbie now because women don't like to
see women hotter than them it's like
this thing I don't know
um but anyway so I noticed this trend
again of the amazing wives
and mothers and women of
um my generation and the generation
above me
um seeking validation
um so
there was a guy named Travis on Twitter
and he tweets apparently this is
considered plus size I don't see it
she's absolutely gorgeous thoughts
and Billy says Y'all Scared to date
women over 145 and it's effing annoying
now
guys that lady's fat I don't know what
to tell you I mean she's still beautiful
like I'm not there's some pretty fat
chicks but it's the exception it's not
the rule she'd be way hotter if she was
thin it's honestly like a waste of
beauty imagine you could be that hot fat
and like like if anything guys this
shows how valuable beauty is it's like
in it she's wasting it right so okay
alien America depends on her height 145
better be six too
now this this tweet
triggered triggered all of the women
now
um liberal not Lefty says the left is
120 the right is 145. five foot two it's
concerning how many young conservative
men's have never seen a female up close
please leave your bedroom fine Buddies
go to camp and try shrooms with dance
talk to pretty girls do silly things
lift now this is a shaming tactic that I
see and it's always so funny because
it's always the women that are
chronically online telling the men to
just go outside let me see so on the
right she's less hot than the left like
and it's so funny because these girls
will put on more makeup and get a little
better lighting and maybe it's a better
picture but I mean guys the the thinner
you are the better and I really think
we've brainwashed a society our society
into thinking fat chicks are thin
I don't know what to tell you guys um it
is what it is and it's so funny the
second men have a preference what do
women do we Shame Shame insult guilt
need to be right
um yeah lady hotter on the left less hot
on the right maybe a little better
makeup and Lighting on the right next
yeah um yeah no five nine and 143 yeah
and you'd be hotter at 120. I don't know
what to tell like guys like it says it
it doesn't mean you're ugly but guys you
realize most women were like 120 pounds
100 years ago
yup yup sieve get mad ladies five five
and a hundred and fifty awesome thank
you thank you do you see these are the
replies that we get
I don't want to see your half naked but
you know since you're half naked I'm
gonna say
you could probably lose 10 15 pounds I'm
I'm not saying I I shouldn't either
right but guys it's like we can't even
acknowledge the ideal that's what's
annoying to me is you know a guys can
play basketball
and go to the NBA games and say that is
the ideal that is what we should be
working towards they could say Hey you
know those rich men in Corporate America
that own businesses or you know whatever
whatever job women you know tend to like
or whatever
um they'll see that's the ideal husband
even if it's not them right but women
when men say that's the ideal they they
feel the immediate need to shame it and
tell them oh no no no but I'm hot I'm a
hottie I'm a hot mom and it's just crazy
it's like why are these wives and
mothers tweeting at this poor man so he
says I accidentally cracked the code on
how to get women to share their
underwear picks online
unsolicited poke at their insecurity
yeah yeah this is so crazy I I couldn't
this just reminded me of my um escapades
you know talking about how the younger
women are hotter the thinner women are
hotter
water is wet the sky is blue it's like
it's so funny how some things I say
sound so extreme but really it's not so
you know because everybody was telling
me Pearl
Pearl Pearl Pearl
um it's not healthy they that's too thin
120 that's just way too thin
um what was the average weight of women
in the 1800s in 1898 the newspaper
reported that the average weight of a
man was 140 pounds and a woman 123
pounds with the average male height
about five foot six only one out of 208
men exceed six feet tall
so yeah and so I tweeted that don't
shoot the messenger fatties
and what do the women do they get mad
it's like I I don't know what to tell
you if it doesn't apply Let it Fly I saw
a chick that um had a workout picture
right and this girl was an amazing
phenomenal shape she was six foot and
she said I'm 185 pounds and this lady
looked awesome and was she crying and
whining that the men were saying that
women at her weight were fat no
because
she know and I want to clarify she
didn't tweet about this story she had
like a separate a separate tweet so it
was like something else it was just I'm
185 pounds I squat this whatever and
what she wasn't caring about this
because she knew it didn't apply to her
so if it doesn't apply to you stop
whining guys I'm just all right your
fellow Americans are always going to
tell you 145 is normal because 40 of
people are obese in America right now
alien America says he's realizing that I
think the men should keep demanding
thinner and thinner and hotter and
hotter why not
um Ashley Sinclair says I wasn't even
145 pounds when I was pregnant and I'm
5'4
yeah I mean and this is the thing guys
not everybody's gonna be the ideal and
if you're not the ideal shut up like
that's why I think let the men demand
what they want stop like bitching and
showing me your selfies telling me about
how hot you are I don't care like nobody
cares and this kind of goes to a problem
in society you know I just think women
we start to believe we actually look
like our filters online you know and I'm
going to give you guys an example in
this story you know a lot of times and I
I found this out I guess all the cameras
and stuff just kind of make us a little
hotter you ever meet people in real life
and you're like damn you're uglier than
I thought
I have this thought all the time with
on my show I'll tell you this
because
um well the other way around I'll meet
them they'll be cool like they'll be
nice whatever and sometimes I'll follow
them after
half these chicks look nothing like
their profiles and so then it's like we
start to women we just believe
whatever's in our ear I swear and we
just start to believe that we actually
look like that so you know here is um a
lady with a selfie without the filter
and with it guys this is crazy like
there is no reason that woman should
believe that she looks like that Isabel
uh Riley Moody says this is terrifying
uh Michael Parson says wish the oil
filter in my SUV worked this well my
engine would run forever and this is
just part of the problem this is why
we're so deluded because man
if they tell us what we want then all
the other women come in and just caught
I'm so guys I'm so sick of being
pandered too we're done we are we are as
women we need to come together and say
we are done with the pandering we are
done with the coddling because this is
what will happen men will say I like hot
young chicks and then all the other
women will be like oh don't be a
doomsday or don't be a doom and gloom
lady
um no that doesn't help us
um selling dreams does not help women it
actually keeps a single childless and
alone and this right there these filters
are dreams
um maybe they should ban filters
guys do you think that women that use
filters on their dating apps should be
banned for fraud
like if a guy lies about his money
that's that's pretty deceitful why do we
have these filters you know and I
actually I had this thought I don't
trust women that are too good at selfies
and makeup I had this thought and it's
so funny I tweet this stuff and they'll
be like not all women if it doesn't
apply Let it Fly shut up ladies like
it because I had this thought I was like
how long did you have to stare at
yourself in the mirror to get good at
taking selfies like how long how many
pictures did you have to take of
yourself to become an expert selfier how
how long did you have to look at
yourself and think how do I make myself
hotter to transform yourself into a
different person and I had this thought
and I was like you know I think it kind
of Screams narcissism and I think that's
really the problem in with with us
nowadays us chicks we just think we're
amazing all the time
and I think a big part of this delusion
is not having consequences for our
action women will do all types of
craziness and have zero consequences for
the decisions that we make
um and what made me think of this is
there was a man that actually cut his
wife's head off
after DNA proved six kids were not hits
now I don't
obviously cutting off the head off was
obviously you know don't do that but but
you know it kind of shows an issue which
one there are many men raising kids that
are not theirs this is common you know
they say out of DNA tests that are done
a third of them
it's not actually their kid and that's
just a third of the ones that get tested
and you know The Optimist in me says
well maybe that's like a higher rate
because those are the ones that go get
it done right so there's suspicion but
the pessimist in me thinks
if it's that many you know it's probably
I mean how many guys are walking through
life with no idea of women's like true
like this type of content is a
mainstream most men have no idea
and my question for the audience really
is what should be the consequence for
women that lie about this stuff you know
in a way he kind of took the law into
his own hands um obviously wrong bad you
know but it really begs the question
should women face jail time for stuff
like this you know and and and that's
the thing guys we wanted equality why is
it that if a man commits fraud he goes
to jail but if a woman commits fraud
there's no consequence and oftentimes
men spend years of their lives their
money their emotional like their
emotional attention their resources I'm
kids that are not theirs there are so
many men that love these children and
think they are theirs and then one day
wake up and find out that their wife was
cheating on them the whole time
and you know
um that's why a lot of the dreams we
sell about women are so dangerous
because it leaves naive men susceptible
to predatory women and there are
predatory women and women are very
deceptive and it's not uncommon for
things like this to happen
um you know and I actually feel bad for
the kids because now they don't have a
dad or a mom
um and we're gonna keep seeing
situations like this
happening over and over again until
really women are held accountable by the
law and it's actually another phenomenon
I've noticed is
men that go crazy and just kill their
whole whole family
um you know I'm not making excuses for
it but it's a really common thing where
they go crazy because the woman
threatens to take the kids away and they
just know they're about to be racked by
this woman or she's already started to
and the guys just get so frustrated so
bent out of shape that they just snap
one day a lot of situations like this in
the news um that Chris guy I think from
Colorado you know the back story behind
that was she was threatening to divorce
him and take the kids away and a lot of
men it's like their whole lives are
ruined you know they've worked for 20 25
years and what what you'll see too is
that the top man so the top like 10 20
percent of men will shame them and say
okay well you can build yourself back up
but that's not really common for the
average guy the average guy really can't
I don't want to say can't because
anything's possible but it's not likely
he's going to do that after he spent 20
30 years building his life and that's
why you keep seeing men opt out of May
urge today there needs to be protections
for men under the law so mandatory DNA
testing at Birth
um getting rid of the child support
system getting rid of the alimony system
um you know women wanted to be equal so
be equal or if you know and rights come
with responsibility right if we want to
give women the benefit of the doubt
under the law then you have to take away
some rights
um you don't if you don't want the
responsibility that comes with it you
can't have every single Freedom that's
just how life works
so as you guys know I'm a I'm a big
Candice Owens fans I I love Candace
Owens I remember a couple years ago when
black lives matter was like in full
swing she was just going crazy on
Twitter and I really wasn't that like
into media at that point like I was I
think I was selling copiers at this time
um it was like around the George Floyd
thing but she got so much media hate oh
my gosh this poor woman and she was
right oh my gosh she was so right like
BLM was a complete scam just like she
said
and now Candace Owens is going on it's
really interesting to see her in like
the red pill space a bit because I think
she's kind of I think she's kind of red
pill so Candace Owens went on the
whatever podcast with a bunch of only
fans chicks and yeah let's let's pull
these clips
for thoughts on the passport Pro
movement of men leaving America for
better wives abroad yes
air quality
wishman I'm I think America passport not
a bro a passport passport says there you
go uh yeah I think that America has
really lowered the cultural standards
for women more than any you don't see
this kind of even the way women dress in
America compared to England fascinates
me and so yeah I I think find a wife do
what you gotta do but also don't
discount the South because there are so
many good women in the south in America
come to Tennessee they're wonderful you
must be in the nice parts of England did
you guys see my Carnival interview
oh no women dress just like Americans
here oh let's not sorry she she married
a very wealthy English guy so maybe
she's just on like the
the average English chick I promise you
I promise you is not much better than
the Americans I mean
maybe like five percent ten percent but
if you look at the average age of first
marriage it's still it's it's more
modern than the US it's 31 here I think
it's 30 in the U.S
foreign
but I will say seeing her on the
whatever podcast was so funny I support
the passport Bros too I really think as
women what we should do is ask well why
are they going overseas and try to learn
you know I mean let's let's be honest
America us American women
really have a leg down you know a lot of
the women overseas were actually sort of
raised to be wives but the women here in
the UK and the U.S really were not
raised at all to be wives like not even
not even slightly so I just say you know
maybe get a lesson learn and you know
one thing I want to learn about is how
inflation is stealing money from us
every single day which is why you should
invest in gold so the US dollar has lost
85 of its value since the 70s when the
dollar decoupled from gold and the
government seems on continuing this
tradition from now until after the next
election the government can print as
much money as they want from the last
time they did that inflation went up
nine percent you know that means one
thing the security of your future and
your family's future is all in your
hands make sure you freeze the value of
the wealth you're holding invest in gold
with Noble gold Investments today gold
is the one asset that is proven to
withstand recession inflation in just
about all economic threats you know
Noble gold Investments is here to help
you if you want to invest in gold you'll
also get a 24 carat quarter ounce gold
standard coin for free
go to
noblegoldinvestments.com now
noblegoldinvestments.com or simply call
1-877-646-5347 the only gold company
that I trust so guys we've talked about
this right we've talked about the synth
epidemic now what is a Sim because a lot
of you know I've been I've been calling
for the men to marry virgins now what
what does this mean does that mean no
man can ever marry a non-virgin no
but what it means is I really think men
need to stop overpaying for women that
do nothing I'll give you an example you
know I have a friend who married who's
marrying a divorce a but what did he get
first he got her to date him for six
years seven years she really did
everything he said for seven years
and after seven years of her utter love
and devotion and really cooking for him
um she helped him build his really good
business like all this stuff he said
okay you know what now you get a ring
and that's my thing like women we just
don't appreciate things that are given
to us for free don't know what it is I
saw this story that I could not believe
this woman
was on Tinder while pregnant
and had a simp come in
on their third fourth date to her birth
of another man's child let's pull the
footage this was my tender day on our
fourth date he came to my son's birth a
lot of people have a lot of questions
about the whole situation so I thought
let's ask you some questions and
interviews so when we were talking on
Tinder and you asked me to go on our
first day did you know that I was
pregnant oh yes I did so I didn't
catfishing everyone thinks like
catfished you and that I rocked up with
a massive box but you were born in the
photos then I wrapped up for next
Saturday midlife crisis and dyed my hair
brunette I love how the hair color is
the only concern that Max has got not
that I'm pregnant when I was supposed to
pick you up from the airport for our
fourth day and my Waters broke early
what was going through your head and why
did you decide to come to the hospital
to support me she liked one of the
biggest events you can have in your life
I just wanted to either be one of the
actuals I think it relates to the saying
if you wanted to he would when I got
rushed into because obviously you were
there through the whole process I bought
a spray paint laboring for that week and
then getting induced when I had to rush
in and get the emergency C-section and
you had to wait for me to come out of
the recovery room what was going through
your head anxious I don't know that's
probably the most anxious I've been in
my life outside of asking you about me
it was such a overwhelming experience
what made you text me in the first place
our entire relationship was held in the
palms of one text message or did you
just go through a bunch of all the girls
and I just hope that one of them would
reply you were different would you I was
different because I was pregnant
with their Essence for you when you knew
that you were committed I wouldn't say
so but it was just such a well
supervisor very a very unique situation
a guy coming in today a pregnant woman
obviously there's social backlash or
people like very piano
what's up I just remember meeting your
mom for the first time oh yes Matt Smith
my mom for the first time at the
hospital once my Waters had broken but
then
Max's parents had heard of me but they
didn't know to the extent in which you
were committed
all right so I got a couple questions
[Music]
why is this chick on Tinder
why are our pregnant women on Tinder now
guys we need to bring back shame so let
me get this straight how many dates was
she going on
and now I know people will be like what
do you want them to do not date like
don't they need to move up yes
yes like there are things
that are just kind of
and my other question is where is the
dad
like where is the father of that child
guys when you think about it what is the
difference between this guy and a guy
that gets cucked so a guy like where the
wife has sex with another guy gets
pregnant and then doesn't tell the dad
the only difference is one knows and one
doesn't it's really just cuckolding on
on some level
um now a couple things I have what she's
doing there was selling dreams selling
dreams this is not going to happen for
women
90 of women that are in this situation
you know she's a pretty blonde chick I
guess she gets away with it
um her odds of divorce are pretty high
but you know I wish her well
um and so like it kind of sends the
message to other women that this is
possible and she deserves it but the
truth of the matter is you don't really
deserve that type of treatment as a
single mom
um you kind of made your bed and you
know she said something if he wanted to
he would but that doesn't mean he should
and I think any reasonable person would
think that's a terrible idea that is a
terrible plant let me get this straight
the character of this woman is it
doesn't seem like the dad's in the
picture she got pregnant and she's on
Tinder
as a long-term prospect that that's not
a good good idea you know I I hope it
works out he seems
he's clearly very nice but but these
type of relationships they just don't
work
um you know and it doesn't really work
when you give women things they don't
deserve and she's getting this like
princess treatment when really
um like what did she do to earn this
just a lot of bad decisions but this is
the problem women we really
a lot of like we just don't really have
consequences for anything because
there's always someone to bail us out
and she made terrible decisions and now
she's getting bailed out and you're
going to see this over and over again
and and so it's interesting because this
is always like the pushback that I get
you know women can sleep around and they
still get married true
women can be single mothers and still
get married not really true um I think
only uh
like roughly 20 of single moms that make
it down the aisle I think another
I think it's like 15 make it down the
aisle another 22 percent cohabitate with
a guy so combined it's like 30
um
so now most single mothers will not have
a happy ending and you know even the
ones that do let's take you know Kim
Kardashian sex tape married again and
again and again uh the the ending is
pretty much the same for most you know
they keep doing the same thing they have
no they don't have any must like imagine
okay if I drink every day I'm gonna go
back to drinking eventually if your your
default is to leave relationships have
toxic relationships and not make
anything last or work
um you're most likely going to go back
to that especially when there's no
accountability on your side which most
women take no accountability uh there
are some women that clean up their act
and get it together but I would say it's
the exception it's not the rule I would
never that's like the uh a mother
imagine getting a girl pregnant and
she's on Tinder like think about how you
know how disrespectful that is but this
is the generation this is why our
generation in general is not really
making it down the aisle
um I would say my generation's like 22
to like
20 23-ish to
30 uh
eight ish year olds
ballpark yeah we're just not that's why
half of us are going to be single and
childless you know she got the kids but
you know
I I don't really see that working out
long term and we need to start shaming
this this is a symbidemic this is this
is
my Lord okay so Al Pacino
okay so let's talk about Al Pacino right
the man the myth The Legend So he
recently was in hot water because he had
a kid with a 29 year old hottie he's 83
his at the time his girlfriend was 29 he
decided to have a kid with her and I
think women get mad about this because
they kind of show how younger women can
just yeah they can compete right for the
top men and he can still do this at that
age women will still do it however you
do get the problem with gold digging
now I can't say I'm shocked that this
happened Al Pacino's girlfriend Nora
alfala reportedly files for full
physical custody of their
three-month-old son so oscar-winning
actor Al Pacino 83 and his girlfriend
Nora
alfala 29 have reached a custody
agreement for their three-month-old son
Roman despite previous breakup rumors
which the couple denied court documents
reveal that Roman will predominantly
stay with alfala with Al Pacino granted
reasonable
visitation rights both having joint
legal custody
alfala initiated the filing process and
Pacino confirmed his biological relation
to Roman media reports initially
suggested a separation but Pacino's
spokesperson refuted this emphasizing
that the couple is still together and
collaborated on a custody plan recent
reports hint that their romantic
relationship while sharing moments
together with alfala seeking more
significant monetary support the couple
was spotted dining together in LA on the
same day the legal papers were filed
their relationship officially announced
in April 2022 and alfala is credited as
a producer for Pacino's upcoming for
um and I'll follow as credited as a
producer for Pacino's upcoming movie
Billy Knight
guys we've just seen this play out too
many times women are women you know uh
it says reasonable custody like when are
women reasonable ever now it's so funny
because I I realize how extreme I sound
to like people that haven't been red
pilled yet I thought about this the
other day a lot of stuff I say like
women aren't reasonable we just always
want more and more and more and we'll
always just try to procure resources
from males this sounds you know evil
whatever
um but
it's just kind of how women are and have
always been you know we have certain
Trends you know women are individuals
some act differently but we seem to fall
follow certain patterns and really the
patterns they don't lie
um so am I shocked that she got the kid
and at three months now they're they're
sort of on the way to separation
and is it shocking to me that she wants
more of a monetary contribution
not at all now uh what the what the
right is gonna do is say oh well he
should have just got a good woman like
wouldn't it be better if he got a older
woman or a more accomplished woman no
women are women
like it's really a roll of the dice it's
based on how we feel so if the woman
feels like she's into you for a lifetime
then she's gonna be a good woman but to
act like we're these like logical
creatures now you're turning us into man
we're not logical or reasonable we just
feel things and how we feel that day is
how we Act and you know you might get
lucky you get a good woman who never
feels that way but I know too many
stories of women being really great
wives and mothers until one day they're
not until one day they go off the rails
uh you know I mean we've seen women
pastors and preachers that start only
fans uh women act one way and we're
Master manipulators you know what I mean
it's just uh
now oh I know what you're thinking Pearl
aren't but men manipulate too oh no
I mean that you saw that one that woman
earlier that convinced the man that six
kids were his
you think a guy is Cape I mean men get
caught dming other girls
like men get caught men can't even get
away with the cheating we're like the
CIA of phones you know so it's like okay
the men they can't even cheat in peace
but us women figure out a way to
convince men that biological kids are
not theirs
women you know I and this might be
cynical
but you know there's negative parts of
male nature too you know if there was
okay okay I'll give you guys this if men
you know had no legal restraints I think
a lot of guys would kill somebody you
know I mean another guy
yeah I mean I mean I think they they
estimate that 10 of our ancestors got
murdered you know but we have systems in
place that say Hey guys if you act on
your male nature
um you're gonna get punished you know I
think women will too right I mean
men and women with killing like women
love to kill their children so I don't
now you I know I know how this sounds
you're like Pearl this is not cynical
well one out of three of us has had an
abortion so it's like I mean I don't
know what to tell you and I did I did
come in with these opinions but then you
just start looking at the patterns and
you're like there really are patterns
for certain women in society
um and even if you look at it's
interesting in history you can look at a
lot of like peasants wives seem to kind
of there were systems to keep them from
acting out right but a lot of these
King's wives were in history
sorry ladies you know
um because they're around all the other
high-value guys and it's the same thing
and I think the problem is we keep
telling everybody that we're so special
and unique and as people we're really
not that special we're unique we're just
people you know we have a nature and the
problem is we equip women
um to act on the worst part of our
nature which is that we're emotional
we're feelings first we're never happy
and a lot of times we get greedy
men are a lot more thankful they're a
lot more like happy to be there thankful
and just like content
sorry ladies it's why you know men will
go to a basketball game and women want
to watch the soap operas women like the
highest and the lows men you know like
the camaraderie the teamwork I
anyways um yeah so I just think we need
I really don't see I really would love
to see traditional marriage come back
but I just don't think they're gonna do
that I I just don't see it coming back
until we change the systems because the
problem is even a religious woman can be
influenced by the media even a religious
woman can be influenced by your friends
even a religious woman can be influenced
by her peer group women are women and
that's that's the problem is we keep
telling men that women aren't women oh
you can find a special woman who's not a
woman no she's still a woman and you
know there's women that are higher risk
and lower risk like I'd imagine
and only fans model with a chest tattoo
I'd say that's much higher risk than the
Virgin bride right but even the Virgin
brought you know I've heard horror
stories you know it's so funny I've
heard horror stories from men that
married virgins I've heard it all uh you
can't really go to school to do what I
do I've interviewed so many hundreds of
people you know I've had consultations
with guys that tell me I married the
Virgin bride and it wasn't what you what
what you say it's cracked up to be and
he's right
because women are women there's lower
risk and there's higher risk but women
are women
um and again we're just brainwashed into
saying female nature is so amazing and
so special and it's like from God and
we're so smart and
not really uh you know I mean they're
smart women there's lower risk women but
they're still women and there's a reason
that in history women really weren't
believed it wasn't for no reason and
that's that's the biggest you know
that's what I've learned a lot of times
there is a reason for things people
always look at history like it's just
these oppressive mean people but a lot
of times there's reasons that we did
what we do now does that mean everything
would work today I don't know the path
moving forward but I think the first
step is acknowledging female nature and
putting in policies that protect men
from female nature and really protect
ourselves from our own nature because a
lot of these women are going to leave
and have horrible lives so it's like
maybe maybe we should we should even
protect our like it's in our own best
interest that time but
you know um let me know what you guys
think uh maybe I'm just too extreme I
don't know
um like the video guys especially like
the video on your way out and really I
think none of these problems would have
happened if women didn't vote you know
let's repeal the 19th baby get yourself
a shirt today a women shouldn't vote
t-shirt at the audacity Network dot
store like the video on your way out
subscribe to to the channel and I'll
talk to you next time